il s'agit d' ordonnance qui seront
rendus sur des points techniques et donc
nous sommes sur ce point technique il va
falloir passer par ordonnance pour
pouvoir accélérer
parce que vous souvenez que le premier
ministre a bien dit que la situation de
la sncf était dans une situation telle
qu'il fallait agir vite et à partir du
moment où sur les points techniques on
agit par ordonnance mais que dans le
même temps on laisse la place à la
concertation
on laisse la place à la négociation avec
l'ensemble des cheminots
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas en quoi cela
pose problème il faut avancer faire en
sorte que ce service a dû prendre la
pose pas de monsieur le ministre parle
effectivement de points techniques comme
vous dites concrètement on parle de quoi
en fait c'est comment aujourd'hui nous
portons un intérêt particulier sur ces
transports du quotidien comment nous
adaptons l'offre ferroviaire à
l'exigence des clients encore à l'exil
en vous nous avez été parlementaire les
parlementaires considèrent que c'est un
déni de démocratie
je ne sais pas interroger interrogé
l'ensemble des parlementaires je n'ai
pas vu sur les réseaux sociaux ou
ailleurs des levées de boucliers de
parlementaires s'agiter sur le recours
aux ordonnances va y aller comme au
sénat par exemple gérard larcher qui lui
c'est un déni de débat en ouvrant le
débat par le passé le président larcher
mais les ordonnances permettent la
concertation nous allons d'ailleurs les
utiliser dans la loi sur la culture
nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure je ne
vois que sur ces points techniques c'est
important mais la négociation et la
concertation
elle doit avoir lieu à corps avec les
cheminots mais il ne peut y avoir de
blocage sur la nécessité de transformer
aujourd'hui la sncf jugement pour que le
service public soit rendue et bien rendu